[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être encore avec nous sur TV 78 après
notre édition spéciale suite aux émeutes
et aux violences
urbaines qui se sont déroulées cette
nuit dans le département voici le reste
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 29 juin dans
les Yvelines
la députée de la troisième
circonscription des Yvelines Béatrice
Piron a mis en action son projet de loi
il vise à former un maximum de personnes
au gestes de premiers secours la semaine
dernière la députée était dans une école
des Clayes-sous-Bois pour sensibiliser
et former les jeunes on fait le point
dans cette émission elle est notre
invitée des nouvelles visiteuses ont
pris place au sein du parc France
Miniature à Élancourt vous les avez
peut-être déjà vu ou plutôt entendu des
abeilles ont été installés dans un
espace sécurisé l'objectif sensibiliser
le public sur leur rôle essentiel et
puis comme d'habitude le jeudi à
l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme la Fête des Loges
qui revient à Saint-Germain-en-Laye la
découverte du karting Electric hospic au
speed Park de Skywest ou encore
l'événement jardin ouvert qui revient
dans toute l'Île-de-France au mois de
juillet et d'août et justement avec nous
pour en parler Marion Aubin bonsoir
alors pour la première fois vous avez
décidé de participer à l'événement
jardin ouvert organisé par la Région
Île-de-France vous êtes la propriétaire
du château de mes dents première
question pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de participer à cette première à
cette édition jardin ouvert pour la
première fois et bien c'est le même
principe que d'ouvrir sa maison toute
l'année c'est de vouloir partager avec
d'autres passionnés de pouvoir échanger
il fallait que le jardin s'épanouit il a
d'abord fallu restaurer ce château
pendant 11 ans
et puis vivre en famille élever les
enfants et puis maintenant on se tourne
un peu plus vers le public on
l'accueille souvent et nous avons voulu
participer en juillet et en août nous
sommes à mes dents et nous sommes
heureux d'accueillir le public qui est
encore francilien à cette époque et donc
on en parlera en détail avec plaisir
tout à l'heure dans cette émission nous
serons également à distance avec un élu
de la région
Île-de-France avec nous également sur ce
plateau Adeline le neveu bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes très belle planeur à
Maisons-Laffitte qu'est-ce que c'est un
travel planner alors je pense qu'ici
tout le monde connaît le concept de
wedding planner et bien moi je fais la
même chose mais dans le domaine des
voyages c'est un concept qui est
différent de celui des agences de voyage
qu'on peut connaître dans le sens où je
ne crée que des voyages sur mesure je
n'ai pas de catalogue je n'ai rien de
préfet en amont et je repars à chaque
fois de zéro avec chaque personne que
j'accompagne l'autre particularité de
l'activité travel planner c'est que je
m'occupe de toute la partie recherche et
création du voyage et ensuite ce sont
les clients qui effectuent les
réservations moi je leur livre un carnet
de voyage au format électronique dans
lequel ils ont tout leur voyage qui est
créé avec plusieurs options pour les
vols et les hébergements des liens les
activités et ils ont juste à dérouler le
carnet de voyage et à cliquer sur les
liens des options qui leur plaisent le
plus pour finaliser les réservations
donc là si je vous demande de créer un
voyage sur mesure à l'île Maurice vous
pouvez me le faire durant cette émission
c'est possible je peux vous donner une
idée sans problème des choses à faire à
voir et de comment penser en voyage à
l'île Maurice tout à fait bah écoutez
Adeline je vais vous laisser travailler
pendant cette émission et puis on en
parlera tout à l'heure également avec
nous également Béatrice Spiron bonsoir
bonsoir alors je le répète vous êtes la
députée de la troisième circonscription
des Yvelines et vous avez mis en action
à un projet de loi qui a été déposé en
2019 la semaine dernière vous étiez dans
l'école René Coty aux Clayes-sous-Bois
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé concrètement
qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place oui
alors depuis 2017 à l'Assemblée
nationale je me suis impliquée sur tout
ce qui parlait de gestes qui sauvent et
donc j'avais organisé des formations au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale avec les
pompiers de Paris et j'avais posé des
uagés en 2019 nous avons une proposition
de loi donc sur le citoyen sauveteur et
donc on constate aujourd'hui en France
qu'on est loin derrière les pays du nord
de l'Europe qui ont des citoyens
beaucoup mieux formés que les Français
beaucoup plus actifs et beaucoup plus
prompte à Inter notamment sur les cas de
malaises cardiaque et donc suite à ce
proposition de loi qui a été votée donc
en 2019 j'avais planifié donc dès 2020
dans le département de réappliquer un
modèle qui est utilisé en Norvège qui a
permis de former beaucoup de Norvégiens
de dire quand même temps qu'on forme des
enfants à l'école puisque l'éducation
nationale forment quand même les élèves
au gestes qui sauvent au PSC1 en même
temps qu'on forme les enfants
sensibiliser leurs parents et donc j'ai
utilisé donc un projet qui avait été
largement déployé donc en Norvège sur
d'abord une école donc aux
Clayes-sous-Bois donc les enfants ont
reçu une journée de formation donc avec
des formateurs de l'éducation nationale
ils ont eu leurs petits diplômes de
super secouristes et en fin de journée
donc après avoir eu leur diplôme et leur
formation ils sont repartis chez eux
avec un quiz un petit livret et une
mignonne donc mignonne c'est un petit
mannequin pour pouvoir sensibiliser et
presque on va dire former leurs parents
et je vous propose qu'on continue d'en
parler un peu plus en détail dans cette
émission sera ce sera vraiment dans
quelques instants juste après les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines c'est vous c'est ninja qui en
est à la présentation bonsoir bonsoir
donc ce sera juste après la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir
quelques éclaircies dans les Yvelines au
niveau des températures ça se rafraîchit
légèrement il fera 15 degrés à
Rambouillet 16 degrés à Versailles et
Houdan et 17 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
dans l'après-midi même tendance le ciel
sera à dégager mais avec quelques nuages
épars côté température il fera 23 degrés
dans le nord et l'ouest des Yvelines et
22 degrés dans le Sud et dans l'est et
demain nous fêterons la saint Martial le
point maintenant sur les informations du
jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc on commence par cette
information Céline a quelques heures
d'une possible troisième nuit de
violence Valérie Pécresse annonce
l'arrêt du trafic des bus et des
tramways dans toute l'Île-de-France dès
20h oui Mathilde de la présidente
d'Île-de-France mobilité Valérie
Pécresse a pris la décision avec la
préfecture de police et les opérateurs
franciliens pour assurer leur protection
que celle des voyageurs de Link
francilienne tous les buts ces tramways
en Île-de-France devront être au dépôt à
21h le trafic ne sera donc pas assuré à
partir de cette heure-là concernant les
bus de 50 ans en Yvelines la circulation
et même suspendue à 20h la RATP demande
au passager d'anticiper leur
déplacements dès maintenant au
tractualité Céline le français davidien
vient d'être élu président du Comité
national olympique tout à fait le
président de l'Union Cycliste
Internationale succède abrigitte Enrique
à la tête du comité national olympique
et sportif français livinoise et ser
cadette du député car le livre avait
démissionné en mai dernier David la
partie avait dirigé de 2009 à 2017 la
Fédération française de cyclisme qui
tient son siège à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et le Conseil d'État confirme
l'interdiction du hijab en compétition
mais ma petite ville restera interdit
dans le football féminin c'est ce qu'a
décidé ce jeudi le Conseil d'État contre
la vie de son rapporteur public qui
avait préconisé la levée de cette
interdiction un recours avait été déposé
il y a trois jours par les îles
la Fédération française de football qui
interdit le port de cette tenue le
Conseil d'État et pourtant aller dans ce
sens en jugeant cette interdiction
adaptée et proportionnée dans son arrêté
l'institution estime que les joueuses
sont bien des usagers d'un service
public et donc pas soumise au devoirs de
neutralité mais que la Fédération
Française de Football peut éditer les
règles qu'elle estime nécessaire au bon
déroulement des matchs l'école des
métiers créative troisième à Élancourt a
mis à l'honneur les élèves de leur
filière jeux vidéo où ils sont plus
d'une centaine d'élèves dans cette
filière aujourd'hui ils ont pu
rencontrer des professionnels de
l'industrie comme
Ubisoft dont Nood ou encore amplitude
studio ce sont de véritables géants dans
le développement de jeux vidéo durant la
rencontre les élèves ont pu leur
présenter une dizaine de jeux vidéo
créés durant l'année ils ont reçu des
retours et conseils sur leurs travaux
plusieurs jours même séduit certains
studios on écoute Thierry Perrot
directeur de la filière c'est le tout
début puisque c'est la première vraie
grande promo de jeux vidéo qui ont va
avoir cette année
c'est vraiment une première ou il y a
autant de jeux en tout cas de produits
on est passé de trois jeux l'année
dernière à 13 jeux cette année donc s'il
y a un bon énorme et bah oui c'est le
moment de faire voir que 3e peut
apporter quelque chose dans cette
industrie et quand je vois le résultat
de tout ce qu'ils ont fait ben j'ai
assez confiance un mot sur l'emploi à
présent Céline on commence avec les
fermes de Gally qui recrutent oui
Mathilde de les fermes de Gally de
Saint-Cyr l'école organise un job dating
ce samedi 1er juillet CDI CDD
apprentissage saisonnier ou encore stage
40 postes sont à pourvoir autour de la
nature et du paysage le rendez-vous est
à 9h30 de 9h30 à 12h30 au sein du
magasin de Saint-Cyr-l'École et quelques
kilomètres plus loin c'est la ville de
Fontenay-le-Fleury qui organise un speed
dating cette fois-ci autour des
associations si vous souhaitez vous
engager comme bénévole mais que vous ne
savez pas encore trop où ni comment
rendez-vous samedi 1er juillet à l'ampli
de 17h à 18h30 sport solidarité
l'agriculture histoire de nombreuses
associations seront là pour vous
informer et vous aiguiller et ce
week-end s'annonce déjà compliqué sur
les routes franciliennes et oui et ce
n'est pas encore les vacances scolaires
mais des difficultés devraient déjà
survenir dès ce vendredi 30 juin selon
Bison Futé la journée sera classée rouge
en Île-de-France dans le sens des
départs il vous est conseillé de quitter
ou traverser l'Île-de-France à 20h la
région est classée orange pour le samedi
préférait un départ avant 8h de la
région pas d'alerte pour le dimanche
bien merci beaucoup Céline Charles pour
toutes ces informations bon courage à
ceux qui prendront la route ce week-end
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
on en parlait en tout début d'émission
la députée de la troisième
circonscription des Yvelines Béatrice
Piron a déposé une proposition de loi en
2019 à l'Assemblée nationale elle
s'intitule agir pour les autres il
s'agit d'un texte de loi qui vise à
créer le statut de citoyen sauveteur
vous nous en parler dans quelques
instants en début d'émission c'est quoi
le statut de citoyen sauveteur alors je
précisais que ce n'était pas ma
proposition de loi c'était une
proposition de loi à laquelle j'ai
contribué qui a été votée donc
effectivement l'assemblée il y a
quelques années et qui s'appelait donc
le citoyen sauveteur
là le projet agir pour les autres est un
projet de l'éducation nationale qui est
en oeuvre donc dans les Yvelines et je
remercie donc la dazen donc moi même
l'air et les services de de la direction
académique qui ont formé donc des
formateurs pour intervenir dans les
écoles et donc tous les enfants donc ont
à la fois une application internet qui
leur apprend donc les premiers des
premières notions de que faire comment
agir pour les autres et là ils ont eu
vendredi donc une journée entière donc
d'initiation donc sur comment protéger
comment alerter et comment secouer
c'était quoi concrètement ces ateliers
ils devaient faire quoi alors ils
apprennent à prévenir donc les secours
donc appeler la gendarmerie les pompiers
ou le SAMU en fonction de l'incident
dont ils sont témoins ils ont appris à
mettre donc un une victime donc en
position latérale de sécurité et ils ont
appris donc à faire un massage cardiaque
voire à utiliser un défibrillateur et
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
mettre ce type de formation en place
dans les écoles c'est face à un stage
les formations existaient jusqu'à
présent mais normalement elles étaient
limitées aux enfants aux élèves et ils
avaient relativement peu de pratique
mais ils étaient quand même initiés là
en fin de compte on a organisé donc des
un investissement un petit peu dans du
matériel donc qui sont des petites des
petits man individuel donc chaque élève
se forme avec son propre mannequin et le
soir il rentre chez lui avec le
mannequin un petit peu comme le pré dans
le livre de bibliothèque donc il ramène
le mannequin chez lui et il va pouvoir
faire la démonstration à ses frères et
sœurs à ses parents de comment est-ce
qu'on fait un massage cardiaque il a
donc le petit livret le petit quiz pour
expliquer à ses parents qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire quand on est face à une
victime avec un malaise cardiaque il
garde donc la mignonne chez lui pendant
une semaine et donc normalement cette
fin de semaine il est censé ramener la
mignonne à son enseignante comme un
simple prêt de bibliothèque pour vous en
France les Français ne sont pas assez
formés
à peu près 50% la population qui ont eu
des formations de gestes qui sauvent ou
de PSC1 donc c'est même un petit peu
inférieur à 50% pour le PSC1 des
sondages bon qui date d'il y a quelques
années de quatre cinq ans indiqué que
devant un malaise cardiaque il y avait
tout juste un Français sur cinq qui osé
faire un massage cardiaque or c'est
primordial de faire immédiatement le
massage cardiaque même si on n'est pas
un faire du massage cardiaque c'est pas
très compliqué la preuve on en prend à
des enfants de 10 ans on peut être formé
à partir de 10 ans l'important est
d'agir vite immédiatement on perd 10% de
chances d'être réanimé toutes les
minutes donc quand on commence dans la
première minute le massage cardiaque on
a 90 % de chances d'être réanimé si on
attend l'arrivée des pompiers et en
moyenne dans les Yvelines les pompiers
arrivent au-delà de 10 minutes 10 15
minutes voilà 13 minutes bah quand vous
comptez 10 minutes 10% de chances d'être
animé toutes les minutes au bout de 10
minutes vous avez très peu de chance
d'être réanimer est-ce que vous partagez
ce constat autour du plateau Adeline le
neveu Marion au bain que que les
Français ne sont pas suffisamment formés
au moins ce que je trouve très
intéressant dans votre démarche c'est de
voir que ce sont les enfants qui vont
éduquer les parents c'est au moins je
pense qu'on pourrait dépasser le sujet
aborder d'autres domaines où les enfants
pourraient aussi éduquer leurs parents
c'est au moins un sujet de conversation
même si la formation n'est pas complète
mais
ce qui serait idéal ça serait que
l'enfant arrive à poser une colle à ses
parents qui ne savent pas lui montrer
que lui c'est et que ça encourage au
moins les adultes à aller se former à ce
documenter à se renseigner et donc vous
êtes inspiré vous le disiez en début
d'émission de l'Europe et en Norvège il
y a 95 % des citoyens qui disent agir
donc la France et dépassée on est en
retard sur ce sujet-là conscience
et donc ce sont c'est une solution que
vous proposez pour rattraper ce retard
oui oui donc il y avait eu un petit élan
de de formation on va dire ou de
générosité des Français en 2016 après
les gros attentats donc de Paris ou il y
avait eu plus de 100 000 personnes qui
s'était formé la même année
ça avait démarré un petit peu puis
malheureusement le covid est venu
freiner tout tous ces élans et toutes
ces préoccupations on va dire de de
gestes qui sauvent pendant une année ou
deux l'urgence était un petit peu
ailleurs et là il faut vraiment se
remettre dans dans le droit chemin
former tous les élèves de 3e donc
aujourd'hui on est à plus de 60% dans
les Yvelines on n'a pas encore 100% tout
à fait des élèves qui sont formés sur le
PSC en troisième normalement tous les
jeux aussi qui font le SNU sortiront
donc avec leur PSA il faudrait que ça
soit la population entière donc les
procédures et je dirais que
l'organisation fait que le flux tous les
jeunes citoyens sont maintenant formés
mais il manque un petit peu le stock on
va dire des adultes et c'est pour ça que
je l'ai lancé ce projet pour que les
enfants sensibilisent leurs parents
alors justement comment est-ce qu'ils
ont réagi les enfants de l'école
élémentaire René Cottier aux
Clayes-sous-Bois ils se sont pris au jeu
moi j'ai été vendredi après-midi ils
avaient donc déjà fait un petit peu de
sensibilisation d'initiation au
préalable ils avaient déjà quelques
notions en tout cas ils sont tous
volontaires et à aucun moment il y a des
craintes ou des risques c'est plutôt aux
adultes qui qui essayent de dire on a
peur sur un massage cardiaque de faire
mal de mal faire
éventuellement il y a toujours un petit
doute par rapport à la mort
tout proche à ce moment là les enfants
se posent pas la question et bien merci
beaucoup Béatrice Piron d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau je le
rappelle vous êtes la député de la
troisième circonscription des Yvelines
des bourdonnements se font entendre à
proximité du sacré-cœur depuis quelques
semaines à peu près 50 000 abeilles ont
élu domicile dans une ruche pédagogique
du parc France Miniature à Élancourt
l'objectif démystifier les abeilles et
sensibiliser le public à leur rôle
central dans les écosystèmes le
reportage de Julien Leroy et de Céline
Charles
qui vient sur mes genoux tous les soirs
me raconter une histoire l'histoire du
soir un lien d'amour entre Jacky et ses
abeilles pour cette apiculteur
plaise est une mission quotidien le 16
juin dernier il s'est associé au parc
France Miniature à Élancourt pour
installer une ruche pédagogique près de
50 000 insectes fourmis au milieu des
monuments grâce à des ouvertures sur la
structure le public peut admirer le
travail complexe de la colonie oui très
bien des abeilles qui ont construit les
alvéoles et qui sont en train de stocker
du bien à l'intérieur
l'objectif c'est de visualiser donc des
abeilles qui sont en pleine activité qui
sont plein labeurs qui participent à
notre bien-être qui vont participer à la
pollinisation des des fleurs bien
entendu ramener du nectar ramener du
pollen rap mais de la propolis Jacky
boisseau a réalisé lui-même la
conception de cette maison pédagogique
pour éviter les piqûres un système de
cheminée culminant à 2m50 du sol permet
aux abeilles d'entrer et de sortir
librement lorsqu'on utilise une ruche
classique elles sortent à 50 cm donc
aura de l'herbe et elles vont décoller
et elles vont décoller elles vont avoir
un petit peu de temps pour monter en
altitude mais elles vont décoller plus
difficilement et donc moins de sécurité
pour les visiteurs du parc l'enjeu à
France Miniature en installant cette rue
cheminée au cœur du parc c'était de
montrer à nos visiteurs que ces petites
abeilles sont pas du tout offensives
quand on les dérange pas et puis surtout
c'était l'occasion pour nous de porter
un message et de sensibiliser à la
préservation de l'environnement des
panneaux éducatifs seront placés dans
les allées durant l'été afin de mieux
comprendre ces espèces pour prolonger
l'expérience des ateliers autour du miel
et des abeilles seront organisées avec
Jacky boisseau durant les journées du
patrimoine les 16 et 17 septembre
prochain
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure à présent de passer
à notre page loisirs
[Musique]
et on va ouvrir cette page loisirs par
un événement les jardins ouverts lancé
par la Région Île-de-France mais juste
avant une journaliste de la rédaction de
tv78 nous a rejoint en plateau Gabriel
Gauthier bonsoir bonsoir Mathieu comme
d'habitude le jeudi vous nous présentez
vos bons plans pour partager un bon
moment dans les Yvelines à l'approche du
week-end un petit teasing mais on
parlera notamment de la réouverture de
la Fête des Loges ça se passe demain
c'est la 370e édition si je me trompe
pas très longtemps avec deux nouvelles
attractions on en parlera dans un
instant ce sera dans un instant vous
l'avez dit avant on va se plonger dans
la 7e édition des jardins ouverts c'est
dans toute l'île de France et ça
commence ce weekend pour en parler avec
nous Marion Aubin la propriétaire du
château de mes dents ou participer pour
la première fois à cet événement et Yann
warly wearling bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président chargé de la biodiversité
pour la région
Île-de-France alors première question
c'est quoi le principe
des jardins ouverts
le principe est très simple il s'agit de
d'identifier des jardins des parcs des
lieux qui sont pas forcément toujours
ouverts toute l'année beaucoup le son
mais pas tous et qui s'ouvre le temps de
l'été donc ça démarre le premier juillet
ça finit fin août et qui s'ouvre tous
les thés à un espèce de mix entre une
offre culturelle et
et une offre de nature voilà donc on lit
deux sujets qui sont très importants à
relier nature et culture c'est vraiment
de de façon de d'aborder la nature ou la
culture qui est tout à fait originale et
c'est la septième édition la septième
année et ça a un grand succès donc on le
renouvelle chaque année et je remercie
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui s'y prêtent
dont madame Aubin au château de Médan
qui qui s'y met cette année et voilà on
a on a vraiment besoin de d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui les les joyaux de
l'Île-de-France que sont les joyaux
naturels et patrimoniaux en négociant
des activités culturelles l'objectif si
je comprends bien c'est d'ouvrir ce
patrimoine naturel d'Île-de-France de
manière un peu insolite de le faire
découvrir de manière insolite
oui absolument il s'agit de le parce que
bon ce sont il y a des fois d'essayer
des parcs qui sont ouverts tout au long
de l'année donc c'est des parts que
qu'elle on peut se promener et là à
l'occasion de l'été il y a des
animations qui ont lieu du théâtre des
concerts des expositions d'art
contemporain qui rendent ces cellules
encore plus vivantes et c'est une
invitation qu'on fait aux Franciliens à
découvrir leur propre patrimoine souvent
pas forcément loin de chez soi donc il y
a quand même 200 lieux à travers toute
l'Île-de-France qui sont ouverts voilà
on voit quelques exemples il y a 200
lieux qui sont ouverts pendant l'été et
donc c'est aussi une manière de
d'envoyer un message à tout le monde qui
est dire pas forcément besoin d'aller
très loin en France ou à l'étranger pour
avoir des vacances réjouissantes il y a
aussi beaucoup de lieux en Île-de-France
qui sont particulièrement intéressants à
découvrir ou à redécouvrir dans son
département dans les Yvelines par
exemple mais aussi c'est l'occasion
d'aller découvrir d'autres choses dans
d'autres départements et découvrir que
l'Île-de-France est extrêmement riche en
lieu de nature et de culture justement
dans les Yvelines combien de lieux
seront ouverts au public ce weekend et
quels seront les animations de
alors il y en a une alors il y a 200
lieux sur toute l'Île-de-France et dans
les Yvelines poser une colle j'ai pas
compté exactement je crois que il y en a
il y en a une bonne vingtaine mais voilà
moi j'en ai repéré quelques-uns au
château de Monte-Cristo bien sûr le
château de Médan ou le domaine de
Dampierre en Yvelines ou le Potager du
Roi la Bergerie Nationale ou la laiterie
Marie-Antoinette il y a il y a sur la
carte que l'on a sur le site de la
Région Île-de-France et si vous y allez
vous allez sur le site de la Région
Île-de-France et vous cherchez jardin
ouvert
dans les onglets vous allez avoir la
liste de l'ensemble des propositions qui
sont faites sur cette sur cette session
2023 et donc on a vu le site internet
s'afficher en bas de notre écran et donc
parmi les participants on le voit sur
ces images le château de Médan Marion
Aubin quel sera le programme de ce
weekend alors ce week-end c'est surtout
dimanche nous avons une poète qui qui
vient de faire publier un livre de
poèmes intitulé Zatar c'est une jeune
femme
Gréco libanaise qui est réfugiée en
France qui a écrit en français
directement et qui vient lire des
extraits de son poème alors ça n'a pas
de lien avec tous ceux qui ont vécu au
château de Médan puisque mes dents c'est
un pavillon de chasse du 15e siècle
quelle est l'histoire de alors voilà
mécène de Pierre de Ronsard et habiter
donc toute la bande de la Pléiade est
venue chasser à mes dents écrire des
poèmes et puis
cette maison est restée dans la même
famille du 15e au 18e siècle et ensuite
il y aura il y aura l'avenue d'Henri IV
qui viendra chasser nous avons trouvé
une date 1599 et puis il y aura le poète
un autre poète le comte Maurice
méterlinque prix Nobel de littérature
belge flamand mais qui écrit en français
et qui écrira une grande partie de son
œuvre à mes dents où il habitera son
épouse était comédienne il avait créé un
théâtre à mes dents et elle a joué
notamment les oeuvres de son mari et
puis le destin a été curieux puisque mes
Ternin que décède son épouse quitte mais
dans et elle finira par donner le
château à un ami qu'elle a rencontré qui
est encore quelqu'un de l'écriture sous
une autre forme puisque c'était un
journaliste d'un patron de journal
c'était le journal Combat et son patron
Henry Smadja qui a malheureusement je
dirais presque aménagé une imprimerie
dans le château pour imprimer son
journal donc vous pouvez imaginer que ça
a abîmé évidemment ceux qui a provoqué
notre arrivée en 1977 avec mon mari qui
a eu ce coup de cœur et nous avons fait
11 années de travaux et c'est pour ça
qu'on a parlé de jardin qu'après parce
qu'il fallait d'abord même si on a
planté des arbres tout de suite mais il
fallait
c'est Madame mais pour les voyages moi
je me cantonne à deux heures d'accueil
de de nos visiteurs ça commence à 15h
c'est à 15h on est à peu près 15h 17h et
alors Yann warning qui me retourne je me
tourne vers vous il y aura deux temps
forts du coup ce premier weekend donc
c'est ce weekend là le premier et le 2
juillet et il y aura également du coup
le dernier weekend c'est les 26 et 27
août ce sont les deux moments forts
moments forts quels sont les animations
de prévues
alors là mieux vaut aller sur le site
internet de la région parce que si je
vous fais la liste des 200 événements
qui vont avoir lieu à l'ouverture et à
la fermeté à la clôture on est encore
ensemble à 23h il y a énormément de
choses qui sont prévues durant ces en
tout cas déjà dès ce weekend vraiment
profitez-en pour regarder cet agenda sur
en ligne sur notre site parce que si
vous ne savez pas quoi faire ce week-end
c'est vraiment l'occasion
de découvrir cette fête des jardins
ouverts avec tous les concerts les
lectures les pièces de théâtre les
déambulations les lectures de poèmes il
y a énormément de choses à faire il y en
a pour tous les goûts
évidemment pour les amateurs évidemment
de culture et de nature bien sûr si vous
aimez laisser se fasse fermer
et les débats et les débats Obs curs
c'est pas là qu'il faudra aller
j'ai envie d'y aller Gabriel bon Adeline
le neveu oui c'est très intéressant je
ne connaissais pas cet événement et
c'est vrai que ça donne envie d'aller
découvrir justement comme comme disait
Yann des joyaux cachés de notre région
et puis de mêler la culture et le
patrimoine c'est toujours intéressant
alors avec un lien avec votre reportage
précédent sur les abeilles puisque
metherlin qui a écrit la vie des
abeilles et qui nous avons du miel
évidemment à la maison tout est lié et
bien merci beaucoup Yann wherling et
Marion Aubin d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions la septième édition de
jardin ouvert ça commence ce samedi 1er
juillet et c'est jusqu'au 27 août et
pour le château de mes dents qui
participe pour la première fois à
l'événement l'ouverture se fera les deux
5 et 6 juillet ainsi que le 27 août la
visite ah non c'est pas juillet
et 26 et 27 au j'avais oublié une merci
beaucoup merci et donc la visite
commence à 15h à 15h et donc on poursuit
cette émission avec vous Adeline le
neveu je le rappelle vous êtes travel
planner c'est à dire que vous créez des
voyages sur mesure et donc en début
d'émission vous avez demandé de créer un
voyage sur mesure à Lille Maurice alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez à nous proposer
alors l'île Maurice déjà c'est une
destination qui est très intéressante
puisque aujourd'hui quand on pense à
l'île Maurice beaucoup l'assimile à une
île où il y a pas grand chose à faire et
où à part rester sur son transat sur les
belles plages de sable blanc voilà ça se
cantonne à ça ce qui n'est pas la
réalité l'île Maurice regorge de tout un
tas de sites de de bâtiments à découvrir
à visiter et donc voilà c'est une
destination vraiment intéressante
puisque je conseille toujours de d'y
passer deux semaines à deux semaines et
demi pour avoir le temps de faire le
tour de l'île c'est une île qui n'est
pas très très grande donc les distances
en voiture se font très bien de louer
une voiture justement pour pouvoir
pouvoir être indépendant et pouvoir
aller visiter tout ce qui peut y avoir à
visiter sur l'île qu'est-ce qui a visité
sur l'île juste il y a plein de choses
on a donc on a des anciennes maisons
coloniales qui ont été restaurées qui
sont se situent au milieu de plantations
canne à sucre ou de plantation de thé
qui sont aujourd'hui des domaines et
donc on peut visiter on peut faire des
dégustations on a le au sud de l'île on
a le port le parc national des gorges de
Rivière Noire où il y a tout un tas de
randonnées différentes à faire on a
aussi donc tout ce qui va être activité
nautique autour voilà de des plages il y
a aussi le jardin des pamplemousses
jardin botanique qui est très connu je
pense que ceux qui qui regardent un
petit peu tout ce qui reportage de
voyage ont en tête la photo avec le
bassin rempli de nénuphar voilà c'est ce
jardin botanique à l'île Maurice
beaucoup d'activités à faire à l'île
Maurice comment est-ce que vous faites
concrètement du coup dans votre travail
pour répertorier toutes ces activités
parce que là vous nous les sortez de
mémoire comment comment est-ce que vous
faites avec
potentiel client les personnes qui
viennent vous voir pour créer un voyage
sur mesure alors en fait je pars de du
projet de voyage de la personne puisque
en fonction de chaque personne que
j'accompagne tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes envies les mêmes idées les mêmes
besoins donc je vais créer le carnet de
voyage et je vais suggérer toutes ces
activités et ses visites en fonction de
ce que chacun aura envie de faire
peut-être que j'aurai des clients qui
vont préférer les activités nautiques
qui vont pas trop aimer la randonnée qui
vont vouloir faire un petit peu de
culturel donc c'est c'est grâce à ça que
je vais créer ce carnet de voyage et
sélectionner toutes les activités qu'il
y a à faire moi c'est un travail que je
fais en amont sur internet avec
aujourd'hui tout ce qui existe on a
beaucoup de choses à disposition même
parfois trop c'est ce qui perd souvent
les les clients et qui fait qu'il se
tournent vers vers les travels planeurs
et donc voilà c'est grâce à internet je
passe aussi beaucoup de coups de fil que
je crée ce carnet de voyage et que je le
fais en fonction vraiment du besoin de
chacun et ça vous arrive justement des
fois d'essayer de les sortir de leur
zone de confort par exemple il y en a
qui veulent y aller que pour la plage et
vous leur proposez d'autres activités
oui ça je propose toujours quand même
quelques activités à côté des choses qui
me paraissent incontournables ou
vraiment qu'il faut faire après voilà
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut
l'avantage de de mon métier c'est que
moi aujourd'hui je propose à mes clients
et après eux ils font ce qu'ils veulent
ils ont ce carnet de voyage ils savent
ce qu'il y a à faire et en fonction du
temps de l'humeur de l'envie ils a dû
ils a juste au jour le jour ce qui ce
qu'ils veulent faire mais oui ça
m'arrive de les sortir de leur zone de
confort et parfois quand ils rentrent
ils me disent merci parce que voilà au
final c'était bien on lui on l'aurait
pas fait nous-mêmes et merci pour ça
donc la principale différence avec une
agence de voyage c'est vraiment le sur
mesure c'est le client qui choisit à la
fin exactement c'est vraiment ce côté
sur mesure on est vraiment sur une
expérience par nos personnaliser et
unique qui correspond vraiment aux
projets de chacun et voilà et ce côté
aussi où chacun reste maître de son
voyage jusqu'au bout dans le sens où
c'est lui qui effectue ses réservations
grâce au carnet de voyage que je lui
envoie et aux différentes options et
liens qu'il y a dans ce carnet de voyage
et du coup pour écrire confectionner
tous ces carnets de voyage vous vous
basez sur les multiples voyages et pays
que vous avez visité c'est vraiment
votre source de création et
d'information oui tout à fait j'ai
beaucoup voyagé j'ai fait un tour du
monde il y a quelques années et donc
c'est vrai que je m'inspire quand j'ai
visité ce pays là je m'inspire en effet
de ce que j'ai pu faire même si le fait
d'être allé dans le pays ne va pas
toujours me servir dans le sens où la
manière dont moi j'ai voyagé dans ce
pays là ne va pas être celle dont mon
client a envie et donc voilà je vais
quand même repartir de zéro et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui je
j'adresse tous les pays de la France à
l'étranger et je crée des voyages
partout dans le monde même si je n'y
suis pas allée puisque voilà je repars
de zéro à chaque fois et vous suggérez
des lectures
à vos clients des lectures des lectures
sur le pays sur
exactement exactement parfois je leur
mets des liens vers des sites vers des
blogs ou vers des guides de voyage aussi
qui peuvent qui peuvent aider tout à
fait
vous parliez des différentes
destinations est-ce qu'il y a des
destinations phares que ce soit en
France ou à l'étranger qui reviennent
régulièrement comme envie de la part de
vos clients oui il y a des destinations
qui reviennent régulièrement je pense
notamment au Japon qui était bien des
derniers pays à rouvrir ses frontières
suite au covid et donc voilà là il y a
beaucoup de gens qui qui veulent partir
au Japon il y a aussi beaucoup de
demandes pour tout ce qui va être la
Tanzanie et Zanzibar qui à l'inverse
n'ont pas fermé vraiment leurs
frontières pendant le covid et donc où
les gens sont allés en masse et donc
voilà c'est aussi une destination phare
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de devenir travel planner c'est
enfin c'est la passion du voyage qui
était trop grande oui c'est ça c'est la
passion du voyage parce que vous ayez
pas du tout ce métier là auparavant pas
du tout j'ai travaillé pendant 10 ans
dans le domaine de la traduction donc
voilà rien à voir avec le domaine des
voyages mais oui les langues parler
anglais voilà ça c'est vrai que que ça
aide beaucoup dans mon quotidien
Aujourd'hui mais en fait voilà en
parallèle je dès que je pouvais je
partais en voyage et un jour voilà il y
a ce projet qui a commencé à germer
parce que j'ai toujours organisé mes
voyages moi de A à Z ça suscitait
beaucoup d'intérêt dans mon entourage et
puis également dans mon entourage me
rendais compte qu'il y avait aussi pas
mal de frustrations quand il rentrait de
voyage parfois avec c'était bien mais
nous avons dû envoyer un voyage sur
mesure mais c'était pas du sur-mesure et
donc je me suis dit c'est dommage parce
que aujourd'hui en voyage c'est beaucoup
d'attente c'est des budgets conséquent
et rentrer avec cette frustration voilà
je trouvais ça très dommage et j'ai
découvert ce concept de travel planner
qui était vraiment l'intermédiaire entre
le fait de le faire par soi-même et
l'agence de voyage et qui permettait de
vraiment faire de vrais voyages sur
mesure personnalisés et uniques et bien
merci beaucoup Adeline le neveu d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes très belle planner
du coup et si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran on
poursuit cette page loisir avec la
découverte d'une activité depuis fin
mars un nouveau speed Park a ouvert ses
portes dans le centre commercial Skywest
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux bowling billard
ou encore salle d'arcade arcade sont
proposés au public et parmi toutes ces
activités du karting électrique la
rédaction de TV 78 à tester
[Musique]
bienvenue aussi par de Skywest on est le
petit dernier bébé donc de la marque ici
nous proposons une vingtaine de pistes
de bowling on a aussi un laser game
des box karaoké et du billard et une
grande salle d'arcade
[Musique]
vous voulez la première fois au monde
une piste de karting qui passe dans un
centre commercial dans l'atrium des
cartes 100% électrique avec deux modes
de jeux soit de la course classique ou
du jeu de type game of cards le principe
c'est que il y a les cibles qui sont
apparents sur la du crochet sur la piste
vous roulez dessus et à chaque fois que
vous voulez dessus il y a un bonus qui
s'affiche sur l'écran vous l'activez et
le but est de ralentir tous vos
adversaires donc c'est vraiment du jeu
ce n'est pas ce n'est plus de la course
c'est implanté sur Skywest 50 ans en
Yvelines parce qu'il y a une très très
grande
vie étudiante donc c'est ça qui est
important et à basse en entreprise peut
aussi très important
[Musique]
on vient d'entendre Joachim Thomas pires
le directeur de speed Park Skywest qui
nous a expliqué le principe des
différentes activités parmi elles il y a
le karting Mathilde et oui le karting la
piste est juste derrière nous Nicolas on
va s'affronter tous les deux il y aura
avec nous Grégory canalet Céline Charles
lou Daddy et William Morel nos deux
stagiaire qui nous ont rejoint pour ce
défi hâte dans des coups de Nicolas
[Musique]
franchement c'est génial ça peut vous
pouvez partir dernier et arriver premier
à la fin c'est juste stratégique en fait
sur un peu dégoûtée je me suis planté
dans le virage là et du coup je les ai
tous perdues alors que j'étais deuxième
et que je leur ai envoyé plein de bombes
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est le jeu
[Musique]
et ben voilà Nicolas je sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé mais moi je me suis
vraiment bien amusée c'était génial avec
les bonus les malus ça change vraiment
tout le jeu en fait c'est pas un karting
normal
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé un moment donné
voilà et donc vous avez vu le quartier
vous avez pu voir aussi sur les images
les jeux d'arcade le karaoké le bowling
il y a plein de choses à faire ici à
speed Park Skywest est ouvert 7 jours
sur 7 en fin d'après-midi jusqu'à
maximum deux heures du matin et donc on
vient d'être joint un plateau par notre
journaliste Nicolas dandry bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde vous vouliez partager
quelque chose
soulignez votre talent au Karting
vous Briez autant qu'en plateau ah c'est
gentil et puis vous le savez c'est ma
dernière apparition en plateau au
quotidien ATV 78 parce que je devais
vers de nouvelles aventures prendre une
autre piste comme comme on peut dire
pour faire le lien avec le karting et je
voulais remercier déjà toute l'équipe de
TV 78 la direction pour leur confiance
la rédaction en chef pour leur confiance
cette année ici à raconter l'histoire
votre histoire vos actualités les
Yvelinois que ce soit dans le domaine
politique économique culturel
patrimonial ou encore social surtout
l'économie puisque ben voilà c'était la
spécialité d'ailleurs petite pub le
skyco en replay sur Youtube consacrée
aux Bourget sur l'aéronautique le
spatial et la défense à 50 ans en
Yvelines donc voilà je voulais juste
vous remercier pour ces moments passés
du bonheur que du bonheur et puis ben
voilà bonne continuation
qui va couler Nicolas bel hommage mais
merci en tout cas pour tout votre
travail accompli ici dans cette chaîne
vous allez nous manquer bien évidemment
il va pleurer un coulisses on poursuit
cette page loisirs par vos idées de
sortie Gabriel alors comme d'habitude le
jeudi vous nous proposez vos bons plans
pour le week dans les Yvelines on
commence par quoi ce soir et bien on
commence Mathilde avec une exposition et
il ne vous reste plus que quelques jours
pour en profiter à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
au Musée départemental Maurice Denis
l'exposition femme avec un S s'achève
figure omniprésente dans les peintures
de Maurice Denis le musée a dédié en
septembre dernier date décidé pardon
d'organiser une exposition dédiée aux
femmes qu'elle soit sujet de la
représentation ou artiste alors parmi
les artistes justement Denis ou encore
Gauguin mais aussi des femmes bien moins
connues et enfin à l'honneur aujourd'hui
pour terminer en beauté de l'exposition
elle se clôturera avec un grand bal
masqué et alors si certains événements
s'achève dans les Yvelines d'autres
débutent c'est le cas de la Fête des
Loges qui ouvre ce week-end à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui à vie aux fans
de sensations fortes ou tout simplement
aux adeptes des ambiances festives
encore une journée à attendre avant la
réouverture de la plus grande fête
foraine estivale de France dès demain et
jusqu'au 20 août vous allez pouvoir
profiter des 200 attractions et
activités que propose la Fête des Loges
alors c'est la 370e édition et pour
cette édition des nouvelles attractions
à la pointe de la technologie assis
ainsi ainsi qu'un espace foot truck mais
les traditions restent vous retrouverez
l'incontournable élection de la reine
des Loges la traditionnelle Saint-Fiacre
et la gourmande allait des cuisines et
on poursuit avec un autre événement
Gabriel qui pourrait nous faire
découvrir quelques talents oui des
talents Yves dinois on l'espère pour ça
18e saison le casting de La France a un
incroyable talent débarque dans le
centre commercial au shopping grand
plaisir alors le casting il est gratuit
ouvert à tous et surtout à tous les
talents chanteurs danseur acrobates
magicien et j'en passe vous avez
rendez-vous samedi à 15h attention pour
les intéresser vous devez vous inscrire
en ligne sur le site casting tour
talent.fr et on vous souhaite bonne
chance des talents Gabriel Mario
on prend la direction de Villepreux à
présent la ville organise ça fait de
l'été oui balle pour enfants concert
soirée DJ ou encore concours de talent
encore une fois les villes provient vont
pouvoir fêter l'été ce samedi au
programme de la journée vous l'avez
compris de nombreuses activités pour les
petits et les grands le thème cette
année Villepreux à d'Incroyable Talent
décidément les Yvelines de quoi
découvrir de belles prestations d'autres
villes seront à la fête ce week-end
également c'est notamment le cas de
Coignières et de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et on termine avec une activité à faire
l'été Gabriel qui elle aussi va ravir
les petits et les grands mais surtout
les gourmands ouais surtout les
gourmands la saison des fruits et
légumes d'été ne vous a certainement pas
échappé de nombreuses villes Yvelines
proposent des cueillettes vous nous en
avez sélectionné quelques-unes Mathilde
on regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier
pour toutes ces idées de sortie c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir un ciel
assez dégagé mais avec la présence de
quelques nuages tout de même au niveau
des températures ça se rafraîchit
légèrement elle fera à 15 à 17 degrés en
moyenne dans l'après-midi même tendance
le ciel sera à dégager mais avec
quelques nuages côté température il fera
23 à 22 degrés en moyenne et pour les
prévisions météo de ce week-end comme
d'habitude c'est désormais Thomas
Fletcher à la présentation c'est devenu
un rendez-vous mais sur quelle
thématique est-il allé vos questionner
cette semaine on va le découvrir tout de
suite dans ce nouveau numéro alors quoi
de beau
alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines déjà sachez que ce week-end on
est gardiens niveau genre international
samedi c'est la journée internationale
du reggae et dimanche c'est aussi la
Journée internationale des ovnis et on
va essayer de voir avec vous si vous y
croyez ou pas moi j'y crois et j'espère
ils sont là donc j'espère qu'on va en
voir on va commencer à observer
[Musique]
bon du coup comme je suis dans l'espace
on va faire la météo depuis l'espace il
y a pas encore de ville sur ces planètes
là mais dans l'idée il a l'air de faire
chaud sur celle-là c'est rouge chaud
voilà je crois que c'est mars en fait
c'est mars sur Mars il a l'air d'avoir
un peu de tempête je pense qu'il y a la
canicule là-bas sans m'avancer on est
posé sur la lune apparemment là il y a
le collègue qui bosse le chatouille
alors Game of Thrones et sur Neptune il
a l'air de faire frais parce que planète
bleue je me dis qu'il fait frais ça
ressemble au froid voilà il avait
peut-être qu'il pleut même je pourrais
prévoir de la pluie là voilà à l'aide
sortez-moi de là
[Musique]
alors ce dimanche c'est la journée
internationale des ovnis vous y croyez
où non
vrai tu crois ou pas
vous êtes un vrai faux alien
est-ce que vous y croyez vous
j'en ai une
j'ai pris le corps de quelqu'un
est-ce que vous croyez aux OVNI monsieur
non
et donc vous allez jamais rien vu
est-ce que vous croyez aux ovnis
identifier sans doute mais ce que vous
voulez faire dire c'est que s'il serait
la manifestation d'une vie
extraterrestre et là non je pense que on
est dans le fantasme salut les gars
est-ce que vous croyez aux ovnis
et vous êtes sûr que vous allez passer
tous mes conneries
sur un extraterrestre bavard vous
connaissez Raël et ce qui se passe c'est
que sur la planète Vega j'ai été
programmée intelligence artificielle on
est bien en avance sur vous alors
j'essaye si vous voulez quand même un
logiciel qui permet de contextualiser ça
que mon intelligence artificielle
intègre bûcheron clown de chez Pinder
ils vont poser une question qui est un
peu sa glaire et compliqué extrêmement
intime
un extraterrestre voilà j'ai deux coeur
non mais c'est Monia qui déconne
alors quoi de beau
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]